Prof: We are coming to a
part of the Quixote,
the core of Part I,
in which Cervantes makes a
display of narrative mastery by
combining the sequential
structure of the chivalric
romance,
whose form he is parodying,
with the multiple story design
of collections of
novelle,
the long short story favored by
Italians from Boccaccio to
Bandello.
How can these two genres be
merged and mixed?
Cervantes achieves it by taking
his protagonist away from the
center of the story while still
engaging him in the unfolding
and resolution of the
intercalated tales involving
Cardenio,
Fernando, Dorotea and Luscinda.
We will get to that,
today and in the next class.
But first, I want to begin by
talking about the role that
memory plays in narrative and
the development of characters.
In the last class,
we saw how interrupted stories
being told by characters led to
the revelation of other stories
not being told or being told
obliquely.
In all of those cases,
memory is the key element.
Don Quixote makes up the
generic chivalric novel,
generic chivalric romance
drawing from his recollections
of the chivalric romances that
he has read in the past.
In the episodes in the Sierra
Morena, there are three moments
when memory plays a crucial
role.
The first is when Cardenio
speaks about how painful the
memory of his betrayal by
Luscinda and Fernando is,
and how he would like to evoke
it, if only to make him have the
strength of mind to commit
suicide.
He says on page 225:
"O memory,
thou mortal enemy of my repose!
why dost thou represent to me
now the incomparable beauty of
that my adored enemy?
Were it not better,
cruel memory,
to put me in my mind of,
and represent to my imagination
what she did then;
that moved by so flagrant
injury, I may strive since,
I do not revenge it at least to
put an end to my life?"
The agonizing recollection of
those events,
of the betrayal,
constitutes the defining story
of Cardenio and the source of
his madness.
It is not just what others did
to him, but what he failed to do
at the decisive moment,
his cowardice,
as he refers to it twice.
He says that he was a coward,
twice.
The second instance when memory
plays a role is when Cardenio
says that he vaguely remembers
the fracas with Don Quixote when
the knight interrupted his
narrative,
the episode is like a hole in
his memory.
This is an example of Cervantes
psychological sophistication
that Cardenio can only remember
the fight with Don Quixote as if
it had been a dream,
but cannot recall what provoked
it.
And I quote from page 245 in
your translation:
"Cardenio hereupon
remembered,
as if it had been a dream,
the quarrel he had with Don
Quixote,
which he related to the
company, but could not recollect
whence it arose."
[Unquote].
Cardenio's story has a gaping
hole, a crack at the climax that
is contained within another
crack, Don Quixote's
interruption.
It is like the scar left by a
deep wound.
This lapse is a clear symptom
of trauma, we would say today.
Cardenio's story is full of
holes, of gaps,
and discontinuities.
The third instance when memory
is highlighted is when Dorotea,
as Princess Micomicona,
forgets her name as she plays
that role when telling the bogus
story of her life,
on page 255--Let's see if I can
find it.
She says...
She is about to start her story
and she says:
"'In the first place,
you must know gentlemen that
may name is...'
Here she stopped short,
having forgot the name the
priest had given her:
but he presently helped her
out,
for he knew what she stopped
at, and said:
'It is no wonder,
madam...'"
And so forth.
As Dorotea says,
she will make up the story
basing it on her recollection of
reading romances of chivalry.
This, by the way,
is an inconsistency either in
Cervantes's case or Dorotea's
own recollections,
when she told her life,
of how her life was,
she said that one of her
entertainments was reading
mostly devout literature.
She didn't mention anything
then about reading romances of
chivalry, but she does now.
So she will make up the story
basing it on her recollection of
reading romances of chivalry,
but the name was not of her
mention but the priest's,
so she quickly forgets it and
has to be prompted.
Since, as we commented,
her story is a translation of
her current predicament into the
discourse of the romances,
her forgetting her name is also
indicative of her traumatized
self.
She has, after all,
assumed other roles after she
was abandoned by Don Fernando,
which is the traumatic event in
her life.
Her sense of identity is frail
and in the process of being
remade.
Now, connected to all of this,
and perhaps the overarching
memory lapse of them all is the
loss of Sancho's ass or dapple,
as the translation calls
him--there's no name,
by the way, for the ass in the
Spanish original,
but I know that in this
translation and the others they
call him "dapple"
because,
I suppose, of his color--So
remember that this theft of
Sancho's ass is left out of the
first edition and Cervantes
hastily restored it in the
second printing,
a few months later.
Memory is not just a repository
of recollections and stories
from the past,
it is that which structures the
self in the present,
and the archive whence
narratives issue flawed and
misshapen no longer a true
reflection of what happened but
revelatory of a truth about a
character's state as he or she
talks now.
So it is a truth about now,
about the present that may be
full of holes,
of misrepresentations about the
past.
It is nevertheless the
repository of stories about the
past.
So it is in that interplay
between that flawed recollection
and the present,
that the stories are told--it's
what I'm driving at.
The representation of all of
this of this interplay of memory
and narrative is the overall
network of interrelated and
intertwined stories that take
place or are told in the Sierra
Morena and resolved at Juan
Palomeque's inn,
after Don Quixote's battle of
the wine skins,
about which we will speak in
the next class.
Now, Cervantes was very much
aware of the complexities of
that construct,
that network of stories.
We read at the beginning of
chapter XXVIII--
and I have a handout for you to
take home,
which is the text that I'm
going to read in Spanish,
and on the back of it,
various excellent translations
of it that I have collected.
You can follow the Spanish on
the Spanish side of the handout,
and it says "No
solo."
This is, we read at the
beginning of chapter XXVIII
after we have heard Cardenio's
tale in two installments.
We have this remarkable
self-referential mock admonition
on the part of the narrator:
"No sólo la dulzura
de su [es decir,
la de Don Quixote]
verdadera historia,
sino de los cuentos y episodios
de ella,
que en parte no son menos
agradables y artificiosos y
verdaderos que la misma
historia,
la cual prosiguiendo su
rastrillado,
torcido y aspado hilo,
cuenta que así
como el cura empezó
a prevenirse."
Now this is,
I regret to say,
Jarvis,
the translation that we are
using this year,
pairs this down to,
quote: "Enjoy the sweets
of his [Don Quixote's true
story]
but also the stories and
episodes of it which are in some
sort no less pleasing artificial
and true than the history
itself,
which resuming the broken
thread of the narration relates
that..."
You can see he's pared it down.
Tobias Smollett's version with
some emendations of my own--
you'll have it on the back,
you'll read under Smollett,
which is the last one:
"In this our age,
in so much in need of enjoying
agreeable entertainments,
not only of his [Don Quixote's]
true and delightful adventures,
but also of the intervening
episodes,
which are no less real,
artful and delicious than the
main story itself,
the twisted reeled and rattled
thread of which is continued
thus,
just as the curate was ready to
offer some consolation to
Cardenio..."
And so forth and so on.
You can see how much Jarvis
left out.
I want to call attention not
just to what the text says,
but to the interruption itself,
which is a speech act that
performs the function of
interrupting in this narrative.
A speech act is an act that a
speaker performs when making an
utterance.
Just as the priest is about to
reply to Cardenio he is
prevented in Smollett's version,
hindered in Jarvis's version by
Dorotea's voice,
which will provide part of the
missing information in
Cardenio's account.
There can be no comforting of
Cardenio yet.
Interruptions rarely promote
comforting.
The words Cervantes used to
refer to the build up or
spooling up of narrative trends,
brings this out.
They are drawn from spinning
linen thread,
"rastrillado,
torcido y aspado"
and are reasonably well
translated by Smollett's as
"twisted,
reeled and raveled,"
but in the original they have,
at least for me,
perhaps because Spanish is my
native language,
a more violent or literal
inflection.
In other words,
"twisted,"
"reeled"
and "raveled"
are common English terms whose
metaphoric origin has now faded.
In Spanish, the words used by
Cervantes applied allegorically
to narrative are shockingly
fresh and evoke more directly
the physical actions they
describe.
'Rastrillar' is to rake
out the excess fibers from the
thread;
'torcer' is to twist
together many strands in order
to make a string or thread,
and 'aspar' is to twist
two sticks to weave together,
to weave strings together,
as is done on a smaller scale
with the needles in knitting,
when you go like this with the
two needles,
so the two sticks are being
aspando.
The cross marriages,
Luscinda with Cardenio--
although she had been married
to Don Fernando,
and Dorotea to Don
Fernando--although she had been
in Cardenio's care,
replicate the positioning and
action of the two sticks used
for aspar,
if you understand what I mean.
In short, the relation among
the stories, including the main
plot is predicated on blunt cuts
and crisscrossing,
not on smooth transitions.
These are made possible by
traumatic interruptions,
which jostle the memory of the
tellers and drive them to reveal
other stories behind the one
they tell,
and also make them disclose
their inner thoughts rounding
out their characters.
But, in addition,
the whole network of stories,
which is like a quilt--to
continue this metaphor having to
do with cloth--
is itself a superb display of
narrative skill and of variety,
which is one of the aims of
Renaissance art.
But the question will always
remain,
in spite of what the narrator
says,
about the relationship of all
of these stories to the main
story of Don Quixote and Sancho.
I'm sketching an answer here
today,
but I must inform you,
and as you will learn in the
prologue of Part II,
Cervantes was criticized for
including all of these stories,
and in the sequel he was
careful to integrate stories
more seamlessly into the main
narrative.
He didn't include a story like
The Novel of the Curious
Impertinent,
about which we will be speaking
in the next class,
whose relationship to the main
story is debatable or
questionable,
and we will talk about it in
the next class.
Now, in the last class I
focused--we will talk about it
in the next class,
did I say the last?
In the next class.
In the last class I focused on
Don Fernando--
remember when I talked about
the mayorazgo and the
segundón and that
whole background.
Let us concentrate today on
Dorotea and Cardenio;
Cardenio.
Edward Dudley,
who's name I put there in case
I don't make it clear,
writes in his superb essay
"The Wild Man Goes
Baroque,"
he writes the following--
I'm going to be glossing some
quotes from Dudley's essay:
"This wild man is
Cardenio,
the soul brother of Don
Quixote, and like him,
a victim of madness.
Their meeting in the Sierra
Morena occurs in an atmosphere
of unspoken attractions,
and Don Quixote,
already mad,
is driven farther into the
shadowed wilderness of his
insanity.
His subsequent imitation of
Cardenio's madness is the high
point of his lunacy."
Unquote.
Dudley is referring to the
episode that I quoted earlier
about the meeting of Cardenio
and Don Quixote,
when the knight seems to
remember having seen Cardenio
earlier.
Now, the difference between the
two is that Cardenio is a poet,
in the Petrarchan vain or
Garcilaso vain,
like Grisóstomo.
So there are parallelisms with
Don Quixote, but there are also
differences.
Dudley goes on to give a
context to the figure of the
wild man.
He says: "The approach to
a wild man hidden in a
threatening wilderness is an
archetypal pattern,
familiar in world folklore and
one utilized by artists again
and again."
Unquote.
He even alludes to a modern
work like Joseph Conrad's
Heart of Darkness,
which, as you know,
is from 1900 the famous novel.
So the story of finding a wild
man in the wilderness is
something that is a folkloric
story.
Dudley cites he-goats and
wolves as akin to Cardenio in
his moments of madness.
I mean, these figures assume
the role of he-goats and of
wolves,
two images that suggest
respectively the problems of sex
and violence that haunted the
seventeenth century;
I would say that haunted all
centuries, but I mean,
he knows, because he has
studied stories in the
seventeenth century.
Dudley claims that,
quote: "Cardenio's problem
is that he cannot talk
effectively,
that he cannot communicate by
means of the spoken word."
Unquote.
And adds that:
"clinically Cardenio's
conditioned has been diagnosed
as a case of zoanthropy."
Zoanthropy, animal-man,
man becoming like an animal.
As for the relationship between
Don Fernando and Cardenio,
Dudley sees a homosexual
pattern.
He suggests that the
relationship between Cardenio
and Fernando shows some mutual
affection,
that in a way anticipate the
relationship between the two
protagonists of The Novel of
the Curious Impertinent that
we will be discussing in the
next class.
That is, that the relationship
between these two men is
mediated by Luscinda,
but that actually,
it is a homosexual relationship
between the two of them.
More inline with what I have
been saying about interruptions,
Dudley says that in asking
Cardenio to tell his story,
quote: "Don Quixote
anticipates the twentieth
century analyst who begins the
cure by having the patient tell
his story,
and it is in the story that the
cause of the madness is found,
just as it is by means of Don
Quixote's intervention that the
cure is initiated.
But as he proceeds,
it becomes apparent that the
real reason is that he is
autistic and wants,
above all, not to be challenged
in his dubious interpretation of
the events."
I will say that it's not that
he's autistic but that he has
been traumatized,
and that trauma has caused
something akin to autism,
but it is not autism.
And then he says that:
"Dorotea plays an
important role,
because Dorotea appears before
Cardenio and he admires her
beauty,
but does not lust after her,
and that in that process
Cardenio's cure has begun."
And this is a typically
Renaissance idea of a cure
provoked by the contemplation of
beauty.
This is the role that Dorotea
plays in the cure of Cardenio.
Cardenio's character flaws and
his intermittent bouts of
madness are perhaps the reasons
why Shakespeare found Cardenio
compelling and wrote a play
about him,
a play that was lost,
by the way.
It is known that Shakespeare
wrote a play based on Cardenio.
Remember, the Quixote
appeared in translation in 1611,
so Shakespeare had time,
and he did,
to read Don Quixote,
and to read the story,
and to write a play based on
this character.
Unfortunately,
it was lost,
but one is left to wonder,
what did Shakespeare find
compelling in the character of
Cardenio?
I would say,
of course, there is a
Hamlet-like tendency to
hesitation in Cardenio that
Shakespeare may have found
attractive.
Of course--could you close that
window so that we don't hear the
gentlemen outside laughing at
each other's jokes?
You can also yell out and tell
them to shut up,
but...
No.
I think this is pretty good.
So one interesting topic for a
paper would be to speculate why
Shakespeare wrote a play on
Cardenio along the lines of what
I have suggested,
here but you can come up with
your own ideas.
And, in fact,
a professor from Harvard,
Stephen Greenblatt,
I read in the paper,
not long ago,
actually, he being an expert on
Shakespeare,
wrote a play based on Cardenio.
Literature professors are often
tempted to cross the line and to
write literature.
The results are not always very
felicitous.
But I haven't seen Greenblatt's
play, so I'm not judging it.
Now, Dorotea's story.
As we know and saw in the last
class, Dorotea is seduced by
Fernando, who instead marries
Luscinda.
Is there some kind of
culpability in Dorotea?
Did she not also consider at
the crucial moment what a good
match Fernando would be?
Wasn't she trapped by the fact
that if she resisted,
no one would believe that she
had not allowed Fernando in her
room?
Like Cardenio,
she hesitates at the moment of
truth, but unlike Cardenio she
makes a decision and takes
action.
Hers is not a submissive
surrender.
It is a calculated surrender.
When Fernando disappears she
goes in search of him,
but then discovers that the
marriage to Luscinda may not be
final,
and that she may have a chance
to force him to make good on his
promise.
Remember that Fernando,
she discovers,
has been going hunting after he
left her completely oblivious to
her.
Cardenio, on the other hand,
is pusillanimous,
cowardly, and Luscinda cannot
bring herself to suicide at the
crucial moment as she intended
to do.
Dorotea, on the other hand,
is not passive.
She invents herself like Don
Quixote and like him raises
herself in social class,
ultimately because she does
marry Don Fernando.
We will soon see the role she
plays in bringing a resolution
to the conflicts and prepare the
way for Don Quixote's return to
his village.
Now, Dorotea's story is as
compelling as Cardenio's,
but she is more composed and
determined to obtain some sort
of restitution.
Her situation is complicated by
the fact that her father is Don
Fernando's vassal,
and she could hardly be the one
to seek revenge or compensation
according to custom.
But by law, she had recourse to
both, to revenge and
compensation,
but usually with the help of a
man.
Legislation in the wake of the
Catholic kings program to reign
in the aristocracy made it a
crime for noblemen to take
advantage of peasant women.
Cardenio, being a man and an
aristocrat, like Don Fernando
and the Duke,
offers to stand up for her,
clearly because it is also in
his interest.
He makes the promise in strict
accordance to law and custom.
He says that he will challenge
Fernando to a dual using the
word "riepto,"
which is an old Spanish word
for "retar,"
and which was part of Spanish
legislation in the Middle Ages,
but that had been banned by
legislation in the sixteenth
century.
That is, by the sixteenth
century noblemen were not
allowed to duel with each other
over an issue.
But there was a lot of debate
because, of course,
the aristocracy wanted to
retain that right,
which went back to Visigothic
times when noblemen took care of
these issues by fighting each
other.
Now, that he's reassured of
Luscinda's virginal condition--
and this is crucial--and the
questionable legality of her
marriage to Don Fernando,
Cardenio is encouraged to take
action,
and he invokes what he believes
to be his right.
Dorotea's story is briefly
interrupted by Cardenio,
who cannot refrain from saying
something when he hears about
his own misfortunes from her
point of view.
This is the rest of his own
story, which he himself did not
know,
and when he reveals to Dorotea
his identity,
parts of her story that she did
not know fall into place.
The interruptions are like the
scenes between the pieces of a
large puzzle.
For Cardenio,
the crucial piece is the scene
of the wedding of Luscinda and
Don Fernando,
which had appeared
proleptically in the chivalric
story that he blurted out,
when Don Quixote interrupted
him, the business about Queen
Madasima and the surgeon having
had an affair--
remember that psychotic version
that he had in his mind about
the deflowering of Luscinda.
But now, he and Dorotea begin
to discern a potential happy
ending to their misfortunes at
the intersection of their
stories,
when they hear each other's
stories.
The deleted motive,
the gap in the story concerns
the legality of Fernando's and
Luscinda's marriage and her
retaining her virginity.
It is that chasm,
fraught with violence and
erased from Cardenio's memory,
that needs to be filled in the
melodramatic and conclusive
scene at Juan Palomeque's inn.
Cardenio expresses his desire
for restitution using legal
terms to describe the damage
inflicted on him and Luscinda.
On page 245,
it says: "There is still
room for us to hope that heaven
will restore to each of us our
own since it is not yet
alienated, nor past
recovery."
These are crucial words.
The original reads:
"Bien podemos esperar
que el cielo nos restituya lo
que es nuestro,
pues está
todavía en su ser y no
se ha enajenado ni
deshecho."
The last part is a notarial
formula used in contracts
involving the assessment of
properties and their resale
value,
when returned to the original
owner.
I think, too,
that "todavía
está en su ser"
it remains whole in its
integrity,
is a euphemism to say that
Luscinda is still a virgin,
as does
"deshecho,"
undone.
This invocation of heaven means
that,
once rescued from the
wilderness, the law,
both human and divine will
again take effect and their
story will have a happy ending,
once they have left that wild
place of the Sierra Morena,
law will again take effect,
human and divine law.
Now, Dorotea is ogled in one of
the most explicitly and
sophisticated erotic scenes in
the Quixote that I hope
you remember.
Like Cardenio,
Dorotea is first a voice,
heard by the barber,
the priest and Cardenio,
who laments her fate.
She is sound before she's a
visible body and she will become
a very visible body indeed.
Sancho, remember,
has left to fetch Don Quixote
and Cardenio,
the priest and the barber,
discover the beautiful Dorotea
in a shady spot,
washing her feet in a brook.
She's disguised as a farm hand,
but soon, by spreading her
gorgeous blonde hair,
she reveals herself as a very
beautiful young woman.
Her beautiful,
harmonious body is seen in
stages by the men who spy on her
without being seen--
the pleasure of voyeurism,
is not just seeing,
but not being seen.
Dorotea is the object of
converging gazes that possess
her by parts;
first, and insistently and
fetishistically,
her feet--You have all,
I'm sure, even in your youthful
age heard about foot fetishes.
When I was a graduate student
here at Yale,
there was a foot kisser in the
library,
a guy who, if a woman was
sitting at one of these desks
that have a front like this,
but nothing underneath,
he would come up and take her
shoe off,
kiss her foot, and run away.
And I don't know if he was ever
caught, but there was a warning
about a foot kisser in Sterling
Memorial Library.
I tell you these stories so
that you remember about
Dorotea's feet--Their desiring
gazes cut the body in parts,
a violent act of possession.
Dorotea, who,
as an ensemble embodies perfect
beauty, is consumed by the men
looking at her in pieces.
She is a version of Diana in
Greek mythology and of Susanna
in the Book of Daniel,
women who were observed naked
by voyeuristic men.
In Roman mythology,
Diana was the goddess of the
hunt being associated with wild
animals and woodland and also of
the moon.
Along her main attributes Diana
was an emblem of chastity.
Oak groves were especially
sacred to her.
If her figure in art appears
accompanied by a deer--
this is because Diana was the
patroness of hunting--
the deer may also offer a
covert reference to the myth of
Acteon.
Acteon, who saw her bathing
naked.
Diana transformed Acteon into a
stag, and set his own hunting
dogs to tear him apart.
Susanna or Shoshana,
Lily, is one of the additions
to the book of Daniel accepted
by the Catholic and Eastern
Orthodox churches.
As the story goes,
a beautiful Hebrew wife is
falsely accused by lecherous
voyeurs.
As she bathes in her garden,
having sent her attendants
away, two lusty elders secretly
observe the lovely Susanna.
When she makes her way back to
her house,
they accost her,
threatening to claim that she
was meeting a young man in the
garden,
unless she agrees to have sex
with them.
She refuses to be blackmailed,
and is arrested and about to be
put to death for promiscuity
when a young man,
named Daniel,
interrupts the proceedings and
he finally gets the two old men
to contradict each other when he
cross examines them,
and they are executed,
and so virtue triumphs.
But the crucial image here is
that of Susanna being observed,
ogled by the two men,
the two old men and of Acteon
looking at Diana naked bathing.
So this is what is behind this
beautiful scene that I point you
to in page 231 of your
translation.
It is too long for me to read
completely, but just remember
that these are Cardenio,
the priest and the barber;
Sancho is not with them.
The three men are looking at
her and:
"They drew near so
silently that he [remember they
think it's a he]
did not hear them;
nor was he intent upon anything
but washing his feet,
which were such,
that they seemed to be two
pieces of pure crystal growing
among the other pebbles of the
brook.
They stood in admiration of the
whiteness and beauty of the
feet,
which did not seem to them to
be made for breaking clods,
or following the plough,
as their owner's dress might
have persuaded them they were:
and finding they were not
perceived,
the priest, who went foremost,
made signs to the other two,
to crouch low,
or hide themselves behind some
of the rocks thereabouts:
which they accordingly did,
and stood observing attentively
what the youth was doing."
And then it goes on to describe
how Dorotea washes her feet,
how her hands are beautifully
white,
and her hair cascades down to
the point that it makes Apollo
envious,
as I'm going to say in a minute.
Eventually, they discover to
her who they are,
and a scene ensues.
This is a scene that could be a
Renaissance painting.
And, in fact,
Cervantes was well acquainted
with Italian Renaissance
painting,
for as you know,
having read in the
Casebook,
Cervantes spent a good deal of
time in Italy.
And Professor Frederick de
Armas, at the University of
Chicago,
has written two books about the
impression that Italian art made
on Cervantes,
and the imprint that these
impressions left in this work,
and this is obviously one of
those.
Why is Dorotea a version of the
classical and biblical myth?
It is a Renaissance move,
as it were, on the part of
Cervantes.
This background enhances the
figure, it enhances the figure
to have her be a version of a
classical myth.
It adds to her beauty,
and to the prestige of the
creation,
and also it shows that art can
make the present,
or a present scene,
be like a classical myth--
This is crucial to understand
why the scene is so much like
those Renaissance paintings.
Dorotea's beauty shines through
her course and cross gendering
dress.
In fact, it is enhanced by it,
the contrast,
the misled anticipation--you
begin to see what you think is a
male and suddenly,
as the person disrobes,
it begins to show female
features,
and the gradual revelation of
body parts.
These are all very erotic
moves, gradual revelation of the
body.
Transvestitism is rampant in
the Sierra Morena,
as you may have noticed.
First, the priest dresses as a
princess;
then, the barber puts on the
dress, when the priest becomes a
little squeamish.
Here, we have characters in
drag, ogling characters in drag.
The barber dressed as a woman
looks upon the beautiful Dorotea
who is dressed like a man.
What does it all mean?
It suggests that in the
disordered world of the woods
this sexuality is so primal that
it antecedes gender
distinctions.
It is a form so generalized
desire.
Transvestitism thus is rampant
in the Sierra Morena.
When the priest addresses
Dorotea, later,
he simply tells her that she
can claim to be whatever she
wants to be man or woman,
meaning that she can use
feminine or masculine endings
and pronouns,
as Spanish allows for gender
distinction in the speaker:
"Dear Madam,
or Dear Sir,
or whatever you please to
be." This is what the
translation says.
That is, the despoblado,
this area in the wilderness is
a place so far outside the law
that genders have yet to be
defined,
and it is even pre-grammatical,
in the sense that it's before
these endings can determine or
express gender.
This is suggested by the
locus amoenus--
remember I have discussed
the locus amoenus or the
pleasant place before,
like the one we found when
Rocinante was aroused by the
mares after the Marcela and
Grisóstomo episode.
The locus amoenus,
which is the perfect site for
amorous exchange,
enhances Dorotea's appeal.
There are light and shade
patterns, there's water that
reflects and distorts.
I'm quoting the translation:
"It was a place through
which there ran a little smooth
stream cool and pleasantly
shaded by some rocks and
neighboring trees."
The waters of the brooks full
of reflections and refractions
that repeat and distort her
image increase her erotic
appeal.
First, her feet in the water
look like pieces of glass,
as transparent as the water
itself.
Later, her hands acquire the
whiteness of snow.
Her golden hair would provoke
the envy of Apollo.
These are symmetries and
reflections concurrent with the
larger ones concerning the
various characters and plot
strands.
I'm trying to establish here a
relationship between these
locus amoenus and what
takes place in it,
and that overall pattern of
these stories.
All of these episodes are made
of correlations between the
plot, the characters,
the settings and the scenes.
Dorotea is a correlative
opposite of Luscinda,
who is aristocratic but has
little money;
Dorotea is rich,
but not aristocratic.
Dorotea is also Cardenio's
counterpart, lost as she is in
the solitudes of the woods,
fleeing disguised from her
fate.
Symmetries and order contrast
with the disorder caused by the
"pestilencia
amorosa",
the amorous pestilence that Don
Quixote spoke about in the
speech of the Golden Age.
That imagined Golden Age and
this locus amoenus are
shown to be artifices that
conceal desire in a semblance of
order,
but ultimately cannot contain
it and violence ensues.
So I want you to have clear in
your mind what is at stake here
in this locus amoenus and
this violent,
not overtly violent,
but this violent possession of
Dorotea by the gaze of these
men,
and the relationship that all
of this has with the overall
pattern of the stories that I am
analyzing here.
Dorotea hurts her feet when she
tries to flee barefooted over
the rocky ground.
She is physically wounded,
as she was when she lost her
virginity to Fernando,
and as she was almost wounded,
again,
when the servant tried to rape
and she threw him over a cliff--
we don't know if he's dead--and
later,
where her employer tried to
seduce her.
These are dangerous woods.
So the story of Cardenio,
Luscinda, Fernando and Dorotea
is told from at least two
perspectives,
both Cardenio's and Dorotea's.
It is also told in various
moments, and with the attendant
interruptions that I have been
mentioning.
All is assembled under the
umbrella of the main story to
get Don Quixote out of the
Sierra Morena and back home.
The stories are all united by
the theme of love,
but considered at many
different levels.
Now, we move on to the
hilarious invention of Princess
Micomicona by the priest and
this whole episode conceived to
try to get Don Quixote back
home,
by inventing a fictional
chivalric romance which will
take him back to his village,
because to reach the kingdom of
Micomicón he will have
to,
according to the story they
tell him,
go by his village.
So Dorotea's story as Princess
Micomicona is a translation of
her real situation.
Javier Herrero,
I put his name there.
He is a good friend of mine,
with whom I agree and disagree
always respectfully.
He summarizes the situation
thus:
"Princess Micomicona,
of the kingdom of
Micomicón,
is the daughter of a magician
king Tinacrio,
the wise man,
and the Queen Jaramilla.
By means of his science the
king finds out that some day the
princess will be an orphan,
and a terrible giant,
Pandafilando de la Fosca Vista,
[whom we have met before]
so called because he squints to
frighten people will usurp the
kingdom.
The king further prophesied
that only one knight could
defeat the giant,
the famous Spaniard,
Don Quixote de la Mancha."
That's the synopsis that Javier
gives us.
There is substance to
characters invented by
characters;
that is, Pandafilando de la
Fosca Vista,
and Princess Micomicona,
and Tinacrio the Wise are all
characters invented by the
priest and performed by Dorotea!
So these characters invented by
characters acquire substance
within the fiction;
they are meta-fictional
characters.
Now, Pandafilando's name
suggests lust.
He is a pan-philanderer.
What is a philanderer?
Philanderer is a man who has
many love affairs.
So "pan,"
generalized,
"philanderer."
Actually, if you back to the
Greek, it's lover of man,
but pan philanderer,
he is a pan lover,
a persistent,
recidivist, insistent,
prolific lover;
this is Pandafilando,
this imagined giant.
The name Micomicona is at first
glance funny,
it sounds funny.
But it has several resonances.
It has to do with monkeys.
She is from Micomicón,
the kingdom of monkeys.
"Mono"
is the most common word for
"monkey"
in Spanish,
but "mico"
means "monkey"
in a more general way.
What do monkeys do?
Monkey see, monkey do.
Monkeys imitate humans in a
comical way, only form,
not substance;
they are like parodies of us.
If you've been to the zoo and
you stand in front of the monkey
cage and you see that they seem
to be making fun of us by
imitating us.
Indirectly and humorously,
the issue of mimesis is brought
up here by Cervantes.
Mimesis was the Renaissance
doctrine of imitation,
the imitation of the classics;
the imitation of the classic
models to come closer to the
imitation of reality.
Mimesis has to do with
representation.
You can hear its etymological
relatives: to mimic,
to mime, and mimetic,
and one can hear even a faint
echo of mimesis in Micomicona.
But Micomicona,
here, means that she is from
the kingdom of monkeys,
of a kingdom of representation,
a kingdom of parodies.
This is what this means.
But Micomicona is here also
Dulcinea's rival,
because Sancho wants very badly
for his master to marry the
princess so that he can get his
kingdom.
She is a copy of Dulcinea,
or an echo of Dulcinea,
remember that Dulcinea and
Dorotea rhyme.
Now, the Dulcinea who now
appears is the one that Sancho
makes up in his lie about his
visit to her--
Remember, the kind of brawny,
smelly,
Dulcinea who gives him a piece
of cheese.
He gets next to her and he
says, she's tall,
and she smells,
and Don Quixote says,
how could she smell?
You were probably smelling
yourself, and Sancho said,
yes, it could because I smell
like that sometimes.
It's all very funny--But why is
Sancho telling the lie?
Because Sancho wants Don
Quixote to marry the princess,
so he's trying to bring
Dulcinea down,
to make her look bad;
but Don Quixote is not
deterred, he says,
no, no, no, you must have this
wrong.
Now, so remember that Dorotea
and Dulcinea rhyme,
which underscores the
relationship that they have at
this very heady now
meta-fictional level.
See?
This is a meta-fictional level
what the characters are
creating,
what the priest is creating,
what Dorotea is creating by
representing by performing the
story,
and what Sancho is creating
with his lie.
Now, we know now what is behind
the lie, Sancho's lie.
Remember, all of these stories
always have something behind
them, or are always telling
another story.
The story being told here is
that Sancho wants Don Quixote to
marry the Princess Micomicona,
not to marry Dulcinea so he's
trying to make her look bad.
There is another rhyming echo
here that reveals to what extent
the story that Dorotea is
telling is a version of her own
predicament: "Pandafilando,
Fernando,"
"Pandafilando,
Fernando."
You see?
There is a connection here,
an oral connection between the
two characters.
So this character who is
lustful, and that Herrero will
claim later is an allegory of
lust itself.
Now, at one point,
nearly everybody here is in
disguise.
Some men have been in drag
playing various roles,
even Sancho is playing the role
of the squire of a bogus
knight-errant.
The deep question about this
episode with these
meta-fictional levels is about
the theatricality of life.
This is where the
Quixote leads us,
again, to ask questions that
are pertinent and relevant to
our lives.
Is living the playing of roles?
Are we characters in somebody
else's fiction as these
characters are here?
And if so, for instance,
are we bound by ethics if we
are just mere characters in
somebody's fiction?
There are stories within
stories creating the infinitely
receding sequence that I spoke
about before.
We can lose track of the real
and of the self in such a
construct,
as I told you little boys used
to do when they went to the
barber shop and saw all of these
repeated images of themselves--
Who, where are you?
Who are you?
I have heard that under
hypnosis we cannot be made to do
anything that goes against our
sense of values,
against our morals.
However, in dreams we do
transgress principles and engage
in this wish fulfillment
fantasies, in which we
transgress principles.
Freud's The Interpretation
of Dreams, published in
1900,
suggests and has suggested for
the twentieth century an
analogue for literature and for
these levels of fiction.
Where does literature stand
among all of these states of
mind?
In his own dream,
Don Quixote will go on with his
madness, he will continue to be
mad in his dream.
In the stories that they make
up, however,
Micomicona and Sancho do tell
their deeper desires and
apprehensions,
a subconscious force is
stronger than their will to lie.
They want to lie and they and
they tell the truth,
indirectly.
These are the issues that this
complex of stories suggest.
Now, let me talk,
for comic relief,
as we come to the end,
and since we're talking about
values and principles,
about an obscene passage in
the Quixote.
Herrero--Javier--claims that
the "rabo,"
the tail that the barber
borrows for the innkeeper's wife
means her genitals,
and that the obscene reference
to it leads to an identification
of Pandafilando with the
phallus.
Hence, Don Quixote cuts off a
phallus, the symbol of lust.
I think that it is mostly just
a dirty joke on the part of
Cervantes,
who is having fun with a keen
reader that he imagines could
understand the obscenity behind
this.
The innkeeper's wife says--and
I'm going to read it first in
Spanish:
"Para mí
santiguada [you remember that
they borrow the oxtails that she
had where she kept her comb,
so first the priest and the
barber can make a beard and look
different]
que no se ha aún de
aprovechar más de mi rabo
para su barba,
y que me ha de devolver mi
cola, que anda de lo mi marido
por esos suelos que es una
vergüenza:
digo,
el peine, que solía yo
colgar de mi buena cola."
"By my faith,
[this is Jarvis],
you shall you use my tail no
longer for a beard.
Give me my tail again,
for my husband's thing is
tossed up and down that it is a
shame,
I mean the comb,
I used to stick in my good
tail."
Hmmmm...
Herrero, writes--I think,
over interpreting,
my dear friend:
"This is then the extended
joke the barber has taken away
the innkeeper's wife tail into
which the innkeeper used to put
his thing [this is a translation
literal]
also referred to as his comb.
When the barber gave it back to
her, she complained that it is
completely spoiled,
that it has lost its hair,
and that it will not serve any
longer for what her husband used
it."
Herrero continues:
"As we are going to show
you immediately,
[but I will spare you his
proofs], tail,
rabo or cola
means the loins both male and
female genitals and so the arse,
culo,
and beard has a similar
meaning.
Cervantes has created with is
multiplicity of obscure
meanings,
[I don't think they're very
obscure]
a constellation of sexual
images which are finally
conveyed on the giant
himself."
I can't go there with Javier.
I think that the joke is very
clear;
I don't think it's very
obscure, it's very clear,
and it's very funny.
I don't see how it can be
extended to the giant,
however, but one wonders why
Cervantes included this obscene
joke in the text?
As I said, I think he's just
having fun with the reader who
could pick it up.
Now, the stories,
sub-stories and interruptions
in relation to memory bring to
mind--
going back to the beginning of
my lecture today--
bring to mind the issue of
Cervantes's oversights,
particularly the one about
Sancho's stolen donkey.
What does it mean?
Perhaps that creation is the
flawed product of memory.
One critic has suggested,
as I believe I said before,
that Cervantes included errors
in the Quixote purposely.
I doubt it, because he did try
desperately to fix them within
months.
But the errors are consistent
with certain characteristics of
the Quixote,
such as improvisation and the
faulty or creative nature of
memory.
By making mistakes we create
deviating from models.
What I'm saying is that the
mistakes of memory,
as we've seen in the stories
told by the characters,
are creative.
What is the value of the
sub-texts--
if we could use that word--that
we found beneath the stories
being told,
like the one about Dorotea's
predicament,
and the one that Cardenio is a
really telling?
To learn that sometimes,
perhaps all of the time,
a story is the deflected
version of another.
So what?
So the pleasure lies in the
gradual discovery of the story
within the story,
as with the entire
Quixote.
All this has to do with the
nature of narrative and with the
nature of literature,
a multilayered discourse whose
gist is precisely its hidden
meanings that surface in odd
ways.
Why did Cervantes embed these
stories about Cardenio,
Luscinda, Dorotea and Don
Fernando within the overall
story of the Quixote?
Did he think that they,
or the main story,
could not stand on their own?
The stories are reflections of
the main story as we have seen,
both in their themes and by
their inner structures,
the characters create other
characters,
the stories are broken up and
started again,
many characters displayed some
sort of madness,
they are like mirror images of
Don Quixote.
Mostly, I believe,
Cervantes was searching for a
way to create a new genre,
he did not know yet which,
that would allow for this
mixture,
the sequential plot of the
chivalric romance,
the multistory kind of book
produced by the Italians.
A new genre that would also for
this a mixture of main story and
dependent or lateral stories,
and he did create it,
he created what came to be
known as the novel by doing
this.
Now, beyond literature,
the most significant idea
behind this intermingling and
the errors is to posit that
memory is the self,
that the self is memory with
all of its flaws and its holes
and its gaps.
Remember that the novel,
the Quixote,
begins with a willful act of
forgetting;
that village in La Mancha,
whose name the narrator does
not want to remember.